but Yale the drama school was uh it was
a horrible experience it was yeah why
why um I called it the uh the it was
like uh and I think theater in its own
fashion is like uh you're you're in an
abusive orphanage and that's what yeah
was like you know here's the examples
okay young student coming there uh
really wants to um to you know uh you
know comes from Angeles uh you know and
and it's kind of been trying to get into
film and television but then goes I'm
going to do this instead I'm going to go
to Yale drama school become a really
great actor goes there and within four
months that we have a month off and in
January and the his speech teacher tells
him that he should uh he's got a cilent
s don't I don't even know how to
describe a siant s did you say you're s
like your brother or sister you oh not a
list not a list but it's I forget how
you do it it's a siblin s that's what
they call it look it up please somebody
sibl yeah sound do you have a video I'm
just a history major I don't know how to
spell a siin s y
l s i Sy y b c s y b i l a n t is my
he's got it right there he's got it
right here but can we hear it can you
say is there video on it yeah there is
yep a six minute video that I don't want
to see six minute of cilet SES here's a
two a three minute one wow we're really
we're really going down an
[__] see okay I want to hear what it
is though here it
is the membership feature oh mine or
yours you do we got it we got it you do
it here we go so we could talk about it
at the same area once
everything is that a s ad R siil and s's
there's advertising like
for people are going to sit through
commercials someone said that we had I'd
like to teach you about something called
a cilent or hissing sound listen to me
read these God yeah I know this watch
watch there's birds dish Branch okay box
mess all right now do do you hear how at
the end of each word I made a hissing
sound I more about the birds don't you
think the birds branch sh box that's a
siblin s now you try no I'm not going to
try it listen to the hissing sound
that's made at the end the hissing sound
I don't hear it dish Branch box mess
isn't that how you supposed to do it
that hissing sound is called a sibilant
sound it's called an S it's called an
S all of these sounds are cilent sounds
listen oh this this is just sixes don't
worry yeah yeah no let's get turn it
turn it off this is madness this is
madness that was Madness but but it
aners your story so it didn't really
does it's so he uh comes in we're having
lunch and uh he comes in and he says I
just meant with the speech teacher he
said that the the uh the the hospital
here at Yale is really world class and
that um and since we have like uh you
know an incredible health care plan he
should have his jaw broken in order and
readjusted and uh and uh use the month
and that way when he's healed he won't
have the siil and ass is that a true
story that's an AB I can't if I could
write that stuff I wouldn't be it would
be a great
play it'd be a jaw-dropper no pun
intended no could you imagine I mean
that's do it no I said if you think but
what but this is the way I dealt with Y
so I said to him if you think I'm eating
lunch with you for the next month with a
with your jaw locked and sipping your
your lunch to a straw forget about it I
got up from where I was I walked down to
the drama school I went to the Dena
students there and I said this is no way
to be teaching people you [__] idiot
okay you you talk to these people there
were all sorts of incidents like this
you better here's one your career and my
career' be over it's literally he's told
by an acting teacher another kid uh you
know your problem is is you have to
really change your
personality the teacher told them that
yeah change at Yale Yale
sucks